hi everyone this is rocky nash your
digital life producer with eight news
now standing right out in front of the
virgin
hotels las vegas we're looking forward
to their
opening next week thursday march 25th as
you can see
the property looks to be almost complete
it looks very new
beautiful property and what i hear from
a statement from the company
part of their no nickel and diming
policy is they have no resort fees for
all their properties
it'll be no different for virgin host
house las vegas you remember this used
to be the hard rock
hard rock cafe used to be over there
from the statement it actually read
no nickel and diming policy the company
says they're upfront about pricing they
have no resort fees
also the hotel will have complimentary
self-parking and not charged for wi-fi
so we're all looking forward to that
we're right here off of paradise
isn't that pretty
this is the virgin hotels las vegas
right off of paradise so it's off the
strip
i'm your live producer rocky nash with
eight news now
look for the full story on
eightnewsnow.com